please welcome zacky's day
[Applause]
this is the movie everyone is talking
about right now this is top of the list
this is the must-see what was it like
approaching this western for you
i just did really love the idea of
being a part of this iconic genre but
then putting a
spin on it in multiple ways i think in
the incorporation of the female stories
and having arcs and being actively
engaged in like the whole plot but then
also you know 25 of cowboys were black
people and that's like a lot of people
and i feel like in
in a lot of western stories you don't
see that and so i was interested in
showing something that is also realistic
there were all black towns and there
were people who you know they made their
own businesses and they moved out west
to um you know live liberated lives and
um so i wanted to be part of of that
kind of story and our director is
creatively very involved with jay-z and
so he's very musical who did the music
yeah with him yes so in the script there
was so much music written into it and
there was a lot of rhythm and it just
felt very stylish and that was the
modern edge element so it was just like
a lot of different things i thought this
was like a really fun and great
opportunity
i mean
you and like regina king have this
just knockout drag out insane fight and
it's so exciting
to watch and what was filming that scene
like um it was intense i mean i know you
know like it it's it's like dancing
right you're like learning choreography
but you have to have the stamina for it
and i know regina she was joking like
anybody who's been in a real fight knows
they end in like 20 seconds because it's
exhausting
and it's like this one goes on and on
and on now something i want to talk to
you about is your
climate change series that you do why
did you start doing this and what should
we know about it teach us yeah um so i
have a
a show
on instagram um called the sea talks
climate you know the election was coming
up and i really wanted to um
i don't know have people be thinking
about the climate as the election was
approaching and um you know i think
with the pandemic and everything going
on i just i don't i wanted to also
introduce sort of this idea of hope a
little bit in something that i think
feels very
doom and gloomy if we think about you
know the climate and everything that is
here and is to come um and i also wanted
to incorporate sort of black and brown
voices into this conversation and
it's just wonderful to see that you know
we are humans and we are inventive and
innovative and we have ideas and people
are doing things
and your husband helped you launch this
series right yeah and you're engaged and
you're getting married
yes we've been engaged for a while we
wanted i'm half german and your dad is
german my dad is german and and you
speak fluent german i do yeah and you
basically like speak german with him
when you're together right yes yes yeah
that's our yeah that's our language name
dear oh achievement
thank you you make it sound so much
better all german people are like oh
when i say it's a good one it means i
love you it's it's a good one to know i
also know exit ashfart
oh um austfalt but that's it's okay i
i remember being on a bus with adam
sandler we went to promote the wedding
center in germany and we kept giggling
about exit
because we were like ashford
but you know how do i say it for real
which i guess isn't much better no
anything about it adam and i are just
being teenagers when we're on a german
freeway apparently um
but yeah so we want to maybe have it in
germany that's why i brought up germany
congratulations on your engagement thank
you thank you everybody
okay it's beauty week on our show before
we go
what is your philosophy on beauty and i
heard you have some beauty tips i do i
have a couple of beauty tips give it to
me now i tend to have dry skin and so
shea butter oh yeah is something that
it's it's non-comedogenic and it has
antibacterial properties and so um
that's something you can like slather on
your face and it's thick and rich and it
shouldn't cause it doesn't cause
breakouts it doesn't clog your pores
gives you rich moisture and then also
and this i feel like is
i don't know it feels obvious but it's
really changed my skin rather than just
like using face wash and using my hands
to wash my face but to put it use a
washcloth and like
do it for like 60 seconds really get in
there and um i guess it's just like it's
gentle exfoliation but i've really found
it's made my skin so much
smoother and even and i break out less
um and i i really
i have to say it's really changed my
skin well thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you